as you walk down the halls of the scp
foundation site 19 speaking in the
various windows at the anomalies
contained there you might catch a
glimpse of a dark figure bent over a
table tinkering away like an artisan in
his workshop a vintage black apothecary
bag sits next to him open and if you
stop and watch for a while you'll see
him pull all manner of tools out of it
impossibly large tools things that
shouldn't fit in such a small bag a bone
saw an iv stand jars of fluorescent
liquids and needles the length of your
forearm you shouldn't be surprised this
is a place for impossible things after
all still it's a curious sight the
shadowy man working so diligently so
quietly focused singularly on his craft
whatever that might be
only one thing could distract him from
his efforts
you he feels your gaze on him and he
looks up dark eyes glittering from
behind a beaked ceramic mask he reminds
you of an illustration you once saw in a
book about the black death the gear the
plague doctors wore while treating
patients on their deathbeds hello
he greets you in a friendly heavily
accented voice his eyes crinkle beneath
the mask and if you could see his mouth
you know he'd be smiling how are you
today dear fellow are you feeling quite
well he takes a step toward the window
stretching out one gloved hand and you
suddenly realize that you can't see
where the mask ends and his skin begins
it's not a mask but a part of his face
this is no ordinary man do you require
help i can examine you he offers palm
press flat against the glass a chill
runs up your spine and you realize that
you should definitely not take him up on
his offer no matter how friendly he
seems how good his intentions may be you
wouldn't want to let the plague doctor
treat you he sat in his containment cell
fidgeting with his favorite scalpel he
dragged it over the surface of his work
table back and forth listening to the
sound it made they had tried to
confiscate his table his tools the
guards had quickly learned that he had
more of them in his bag they tried to
take away his bag from him but well that
didn't go over too well for anyone
involved so he was allowed to keep it to
fashion himself a makeshift laboratory
in his lonely little cell there was a
time where they had given him test
subjects fresh corpses from the morgue
for him to dissect and research there
was a time when the doctors here would
come to speak with him talking of
cryptobiology and the pestilence he had
dedicated himself to fighting those days
were long gone he had hidden away pieces
of the corpses tissue samples and jars
of formaldehyde he could pull out when
the monotony became too much but the
days of fresh materials of enlightened
discourse with other men and women of
science were over how he missed those
days the chance to work with others as
he once had what had he done wrong all
he did was treat the sick sure they
didn't always understand their illness
didn't want to receive their medicine
but that wasn't a choice for the patient
to make that should have been up to the
physician perhaps they didn't trust his
expertise didn't see how his work served
the greater good like those who watched
jonas salk invent the polio vaccine or
louis pasteur rid milk of bacteria they
were confused by the advanced scientific
practices and feared that which they did
not understand he could forgive them for
their ignorance he was magnanimous that
way if only they would let him out of
this infernal room he could prove his
work's worth to them he could cure them
all begin a new era of wellness and
peace worldwide he didn't exactly sleep
but when he rested on his little cot in
the corner of the room he dreamed of
that future of a world healed by his
touch a knock at the door stirred him
from his reverie someone someone was at
the door of his containment cell he
glanced at the little window and saw a
guard there with a tray of food he
greeted the man with an enthusiastic
wave sustenance he didn't require the
food for survival of course but it
helped his mind work more efficiently it
reminded him of a time before these
fluorescent lights and these same four
walls of crusty bread with fresh butter
by the banks of the sin the little slot
opened in the door and the tray was
shoved through there was bread just as
he hoped a small dish of butter pot of
jam and a cup of tea still seeming he
picked up the cup at first taking a deep
breath ah
an herbal blend with fresh lavender
lovely he couldn't see the guard through
the window anymore but he called out to
him just the same thank you for the
libations he still had his manners after
all even in confinement he wished he
could have gotten a better look at the
man seen the power of his complexion a
tremor in his hand he thought he had
spotted sweat beating on his forehead
could he be ill the case required
further examination to be certain he
sighed clutching the cup of tea tighter
in frustration why wouldn't they just
let him work why must they scream at the
sight of his efforts flee from his
instruments it didn't seem fair still
the pursuit of science rarely was a
glamorous one he had learned as much
over the centuries one day though
history would look back on him kindly of
this he could be certain he was just
settling in and beginning to spread
butter across the admittedly stale bread
when a horrible sound shook him to
attention he had heard the noise before
though he had never seen its source it
was an ear splitting scream a whale of
pure agony like the sound of a wounded
wild animal he had heard many many
screams during his life from patients
and those who stood in the way of his
work but until he had been brought into
custody of the foundation he had never
heard a scream quite like this one it
was pure rage devastation and suffering
mixed together wet with tears and loud
enough to rip through human vocal folds
whatever was crying out it was no mere
man more screams answered it and these
were very much human these sounds were
more familiar to him shrieks of pain a
fear of desperate but futile attempts to
escape then the meaty thud of bodies
falling to the floor of torn off limbs
hitting walls and windows a loud crash
and the sound of something large moving
quite quickly through the halls
scientific curiosity got the better of
the doctor and he found himself moving
back to his little window face pressed
to the glass so hard his beak nearly
cracked it he couldn't see much of
anything just guards running down the
hall weapons drawn he saw one of them
fire heard the gunshot ring out but what
was he firing at then he saw it a pale
blur darting past the door whatever it
was it didn't so much as flinch when the
bullet ricocheted off its skin a long
thin arm crashed against the door
knocking the doctor backwards into his
work table he steadied himself and
climbed back to his feet taking in the
damage done to the door it was crumpled
in on itself nearly ripped off the
hinges and whatever had plowed into it
was already gone from the sounds of
chaos in the distance it had disappeared
around the corner with the guards
following it he inspected the ruins of
the door to his containment cell it was
useless now hanging loose and open well
that was an invitation he was hardly
about to decline he grabbed his trusty
bag tossed his scalpel back inside and
set off to see what all the commotion
was it was easy enough to follow the
trail of blood stark and vivid red
against the white tile floor and the
sound of gunfire human screams and that
loud long painful whale he had heard
before he walked at a leisurely pace
taking his time until the sound suddenly
stopped he rounded the corner and found
a mound of bodies guards and scientists
beaten and bloodied almost beyond
recognition it was quiet here save for
one sound the sound of weeping there in
the corner huddled over with its face to
the wall was a pale thin figure its
shoulders heaving with the force of its
sobs this poor soul was clearly in great
distress it was a peculiar sight
hairless and white extended arms wrapped
around itself as it cried excuse me the
doctor cried out to the pitiful creature
are you alright
do you need assistance it didn't answer
it just continued to cry had something
so despondent been responsible for this
destruction the dozens of corpses the
smashed in walls the crumbled doors and
shattered windows it seemed impossible
sure it was large and looked strong but
he had never seen a monster cry before
this couldn't be a dangerous creature
not when it was so sad he would help it
but first he would attend to some of
these bodies he sat his bag on the
ground and pulled out several vials of
liquid a set of syringes and a variety
of other surgical tools he might need
now after such a long hiatus he could
resume his work in a meaningful way he
couldn't be certain how long he worked
reviving these poor souls and
reconstructing their bodies as the pale
creature wept in the corner the sobbing
faded into the background for a while
becoming a kind of white noise as he
removed a liver here placed it in a
chest cavity there poked and prodded
injected and extracted testing out new
methods alongside tried and true cures
one by one the milky eyes fluttered open
rigor mortis stiff joints creaked into
motion sallow faces looking at his with
the vacant gratitude he saw in so many
patients over the years he didn't need
to thank him with their words the work
was its own reward he expected more
guards to arrive to attempt to contain
the situation but none came even as the
alarm blared overhead as for the morose
creature he didn't seem to notice his
presence at all not even when he had
brought all of the intact corpses back
to life the patient shuffled around the
room aimlessly waiting for orders of
some kind the doctor tapped one on the
shoulder and handed the reborn man a
vial of thick black medicine give this
to the poor fellow in the corner please
it wasn't much but it should calm him
provide some relief from his suffering
the corpse nodded mouth hanging loose
and open an eyeball dangling unseen from
the socket he shuffled over to the
strange creature and held out the vial
to it it turned lifting its head and as
it locked eyes with the cured patient
something shifted in its face its mouth
opened wide
impossibly wide and a treat that same
terrible sound as before tears streamed
from its colorless eyes its arms shaking
with unbridled rage has its jaws locked
around the patient's head like a boa
constrictor in one fluid motion it
swallowed the revived man whole while
the doctor watched in shock he had been
wrong this was not an innocent creature
caught in the wrong place at the wrong
time this creature whatever it was was
deeply sick he had never seen such an
advanced aggressive case of the
pestilence he'd heard rumors of course
but never encountered it firsthand as a
doctor he had sworn to do no harm but in
a drastic situation drastic measures
have to be taken it was well known by
himself and the doctors at this
foundation that he could cause any and
all biological functions in an organism
to cease with a single touch and so he
approached the creature arm outstretched
ready to administer that necessary touch
to protect the rest of his patients as
he approached the creature turned to him
its eyes wide and blank an endless
stream of tears pouring from them
spilling onto the floor it shrieked
again mouth stretching wide enough to
engulf his entire head and ran toward
him at a breakneck speed i am so sorry
you are not well the doctor said simply
as his hand pressed to the creature's
chest as soon as the tough hide of the
doctor's hand which the uninformed might
mistake for gloves made contact with the
unpigmented skin of the beast its eyes
closed its muscles went slack and it
collapsed to the ground with a mighty
thigh the doctor paced around the fallen
creature taking in the sight then
something strange caught his eye the
creature's chest still rose and fell was
it his imagination he checked its pulse
and thought it was slow and faint and
though was slow and faint it was very
much present the creature was still
alive it had merely been rendered
unconscious by his touch rather than
completely deceased curious
very curious indeed he muttered perhaps
there were comorbidities present other
infections aside from the pestilence
which rendered the creature unnaturally
strong resilient to the usual courses of
treatment what would cause these
abilities this intense aggression it
seemed to be brought on whenever someone
looked at the entity's face if only he
studied psychology more the science of
the mind and its inner workings since he
had no experience with therapy nor was
he certain this creature could
communicate using language at all there
was only one way to find out more about
how this creature's brain worked he
would have to take it apart and see for
himself it was slow work getting the
massive creature back to the doctor's
containment cell he required the help of
his cured patients who grasped it by its
massive limbs and dragged the limp body
through the halls once back in a
familiar environment his work table
ready and waiting the doctor instructed
his assistants to place the new patient
on the table it was a bit small unable
to accommodate the creature's distended
limbs but if he attempted to use an
official foundation laboratory he risked
discovery and subsequent interruption so
it would have to suffice first he set up
an iv stand filled with a vivid green
liquid it was easy to find a vein the
creature's skin was nearly translucent
now that he could be certain the
creature would not wake during surgery
he could make the first incision scalpel
he held out a hand and his favorite
surgical blade was placed in it by one
of the helpful patients thank you he
slid the scalpel along the hairline of
the creature or where the hairline would
be if it weren't completely bald once
the scalp was removed he set it aside
for later when it could be reattached
bonsa please he held out his hand again
and again his assistant gave him the
proper tool this however was when things
got strange the doctor had always been a
deft hand at cutting he'd once even
received tutelage from the great robert
liston but no matter how hard he tried
to saw it never left a scratch on the
creature's skeleton naturally this was
somewhat frustrating he wanted to study
the creature's brain tissue to get a
sense for what was going up there
neurologically and he couldn't do that
if it was impossible to saw off the
creature's cranial cap he blunted two of
his favorite saws while trying
thankfully there was still a solution to
access the beast's gray matter a little
trick he learned while studying the
funerary practices of the ancient
egyptians he produced a long curved hook
from his bag and inserted it up the
creature's nasal passage with some fine
maneuvering he eventually managed to
remove the brain it was such a terrible
shame that he needed to do it piece by
piece via the nasal passage but one
makes do all that was left was to sew
the skin of the creature's head back
into place it was mid-stitch when a
voice interrupted his careful work
nearly making him drop the needle hey
what are you doing he looked up to find
a guard aiming a gun at his face excuse
me i am in surgery at the moment please
do not interrupt he admonished the guard
but the man did not listen or lower his
weapon in fact he shouted something into
the radio code words the doctor didn't
recognize then he fired a bullet into
the skull of the patient standing at his
side how
dare you
the doctor cried readying himself to
confront the guard but it was too late
dozens of other guards were swarming the
room and neutralizing his assistance
some in hazmat suits grabbed his arms
and pulled him away from the creature on
the operating table no matter how hard
he fought or how loudly he protested
then something incredible happened
something wonderful the creature opened
its eyes and sat up it looked directly
at the guard closest to it and the two
saw one another's faces the guard tensed
preparing for the worst but nothing came
the creature simply stared placid and
quiet no screaming no tearing and flesh
no mouth opening wider and wider to
swallow the manhole i did it the doctor
shouted overcome with elation i've cured
you now begins the rest of your happy
life he watched as the guards led the
shockingly calm creature away back to
its containment cell the doctor's door
was repaired and he was returned to his
state of captivity but he never forgot
the patient he helped that day and how
marvelous it felt to do such a good deed
meanwhile
scp-096's brain regrew within the hour
and caused another massive containment
breach murdering a variety of
researchers and guards but the staff
agreed not to tell scp-049 about any of
this better to just let him have this
one he really seemed like he needed a
win now go check out scp-049 the plague
doctor everything you need to know and
scp-096 shy guy escape incident 096-1-a
containment breach for more videos on
today's terrifying combatants